We All Fall Down but John Wick always
seems to get back up this is suit magic
and who's listening in on Assassin radio
anyway spoilers for John Wick 4. as
surprising as it may seem especially for
a franchise as successful and lucrative
as the John Wick series is everyone's
favorite dog-loving assassin appears to
die at the end of John Wick chapter 4.
after Wick refuses to shoot his old
friend Kane in a duel both to protect
Kane's daughter and to take out the
Arrogant Marquis Vincent de grammal
Kane's bullet wounds John critically you
come here thinking there is a way out of
this world for you Mr Wick
or is not though the wound doesn't kill
John immediately it seems to be the
final blow to Jon Aziza comes to the
many other injuries that he's gotten
across the rest of the film from there
the movie cuts to the Bowery King in
Winston they look over John's Tombstone
laid to rest next to the grave of his
wife Helen but is John actually dead
after all we don't see him being buried
furthermore Winston could have helped
fake Jon's death so he could finally
live in peace and he could use the
Bowery King as a legitimate witness
maybe his goodbye is knowing that Jon
wouldn't be able to see him again to be
fair we're hoping Wick gets to find
peace one way or another it makes sense
narratively and thematically to kill him
off and frankly more franchises could
use definitive endings at the end of
John Wick chapter 4 right before the
ending credits roll we see the Bowery
King in Winston pay their last respects
to Jon before leaving however Winston
puts his hand lovingly on Jon's
gravestone tearfully stating goodbye my
son while showcasing a tattoo of John's
family crest on his finger does this
mean that Winston was John Wick's
biological father I don't sit at the
table your family does Winston and
John's being related by blood seems
unlikely for one John is canonically an
orphan and nothing implies that Winston
gave him up as a baby it's more likely
that Winston simply saw Jon as an
adopted son rather than just another
faceless assassin perhaps Winston even
raised John which if so could be a
subplot for the upcoming John Wick
spin-off series at Continental we know
that Jon was raised by the ruska Roma
but since Winston's tattoo is of the
same Crest it could have been a part of
his upbringing as well however it's most
likely Winston saying goodbye my son was
a sign of respect in mourning John's
mysterious parentage is still intriguing
to think about nonetheless
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has had a
profound and Lasting effect on Hollywood
one of the things that helped popularize
is the inclusion of a post-credits scene
obviously the MCU didn't invent these
little teaser moments but Marvel has
certainly helped popularize their
inclusion regardless
after the credits roll on John Wick
chapter 4 we see Kane about to be
reunited with his long-lost daughter
after John Wick sacrificed during their
climactic duel this led to the high
table sparing Kane and Kane's daughter's
lives however earlier in the film while
Kane was still chasing Wick down the
blind assassin got into a deadly sword
fight with another one of Wick and
Kane's old allies the manager of the
Osaka Continental Hotel shimazu Koji
Kane ended up killing Koji in front of
his daughter Akira as a result in the
final scene Akira finds Kane and attacks
him before he can reach his daughter we
don't see the fight itself so several
questions remain did she fight to kill
him or will something or someone
intervene is she or Kane the new face of
the John Wick franchise only time will
tell
one of the main appeals of the John Wick
series besides its Crazy Action stunts
and surprisingly intricate lore and
World building is the fact that the cast
is always full of great actors playing
the colorful and eccentric assassins at
John encounters both his friend or Foe
this includes Willem Dafoe Holly Berry
Angelica Houston and Lawrence Fishburne
in John Wick chapter 4 is no exception
besides Hong Kong Legend Donnie Yan and
current horror icon Bill Skarsgard the
sequel also introduces The Harbinger
played with intriguing intensity by
Clancy Brown what's interesting about
the harbinger is that one of the first
things we see of him is his fingers been
cut off similar to what happened to John
Wick in John wake chapter 3 Parabellum
in that film Wick cuts off his finger to
create a Blood Oath to the high table
which frees him of the bounty on his
head he was also supposed to kill
Winston which he ultimately refused to
do but as Brown's Harbinger is someone
who fulfilled his oath to the high table
maybe that's why he's so obsessed with
the rules especially the old ways and
often talks back to his apparent
Superior the corrupt Marquee because of
this detail it seems like the harbinger
is a foil for Jon his past seems like a
route Jon might have taken had he not
left the Assassin lifestyle behind
at the end of the previous film Winston
betrays Jon who had just risked his life
to protect Winston and his hotel against
an army of highly trained armor-wearing
high table gunmen nonetheless when all
is said and done Winston takes out a
small pistol and shoots Jon multiple
times and knocks him off the rooftop of
the Continental this is because the
adjudicator deconsecrated Winston's
Hotel gentlemen this into
consecrated
Bill grounds menacing voice to the high
table Gabe Winston the choice to get his
hotel back if he killed Jon first
luckily for Jon after following multiple
stories off a rooftop he miraculously
survives he's saved by the Bowery king
and the two plot Revenge however when
Jon meets Winston again in John wake
chapter 4 there seems to be little bad
blood outside of oblique references to
the Past film Wick even comments that
Winston always has an angle Jon seems to
trust Winston enough to agree to his
plan to set up a one-on-one duel with
the Marquee to escape the high table and
coincidentally get the Continental back
there's definitely a bond between the
two and maybe even some understanding
from Jon about the tough situation
Winston was in and it makes a little
sense why he wouldn't be angrier and
possibly vengeful about Winston's Act of
betrayal John Wick chapter 4 like most
of the other films in the series is an
intense globetrotting action thriller
Wick travels from New York to the Middle
East to Japan to New York again to
Berlin to Paris all in an effort to
escape the high table and kill anyone
who gets in his way the problem is a
high table is Nai Omni present and
incredibly wealthy and well connected it
seems extremely unlikely that Wick could
easily board a transcontinental plane or
ship without being identified
immediately or at least it wouldn't be
so easy that it could do it multiple
times throughout the film without any
trouble Wick is a highly trained
assassin but that's because he's
extremely proficient at fighting
Marksmanship and using improvised
weapons his renowned for his prowess at
killing not disguises deception or
subterfuge in fact like James Bond he's
always pretty easily recognized by
fellow assassins despite that being
quite an occupational hazard obviously
airports are awashed in surveillance and
security measures even if Wick has the
requisite fake passports and other
falsified documents the John Wick Series
has shown time and time again that
assassins are everywhere and that their
Tech and resources rival that of world
governments all that being said it's
quite possible that in John Wick chapter
4 John's last Ally Koji ransom one last
favor and gives him safe passage back to
New York
toward the end of John Wick chapter 4
before the climactic duel between Wick
and Kane there is an extended action
scene that pits John against a throng of
thugs throughout Paris
this includes a car chase where Wick
drives a doorless muscle car engages in
a fist fight during the middle of
high-speed traffic at the Arc de triome
and a continuous shot to John Wick
blowing away thugs with a shotgun and an
abandoned building in fact John
encounters the most foes at once in the
entire film during this section that's
because the Marquis is arranged for a
radio station to send a broadcast out to
all the assassins in Paris about the
incredible bounty on Jon's head the
radio station itself is located in the
Eiffel Tower with a DJ somehow keeping
tabs on Wix whereabouts throughout the
fight this does raise a question is this
an assassin-only broadcast or is it
something a random person could tune
into if their antenna got the right
frequency while it's safe to assume the
station is only for Assassins that isn't
ever made explicitly clear in the film
members of The Guild seem to use special
radios that could be encrypted but it's
never addressed specifically if the
radios aren't encrypted there is the
possibility the station is normally a
standard broadcast that is somehow
forced to do the bidding for the high
table from time to time the organization
certainly has its fingers in many pies
after all
John Wick is best known for his prowess
at killing he spends most of the series
run time killing countless goons and
other highly trained assassins with ease
the only thing that gives away his
humanity is that he sometimes seems a
bit winded afterward with a few bloody
scratches on his face and blood stains
on his suits after all that's why we go
to movies like John Wick audiences want
to see bad asses be badasses and kill
people in increasingly violence in
clever ways however movies even over the
top action films need a sense of stakes
how is it then that John Wick seems
relatively unharmed from so many Falls
it's not one time either you could chalk
up his survival in John Wick chapter 3
Parabellum to dumb luck and perseverance
but it happens a couple times in John
Wick chapter 4. we don't mind when this
happens to say Batman or a Looney Tunes
character because surviving Great Falls
makes sense for them it's not so easy to
brush off in the John Wick series though
where gunshots stab wounds and car
crashes all do real damage the only way
it makes sense is if Wick turns out to
have superpowers or is secretly a
cartoon after all
the John Wick films obviously aren't
going for realism first and foremost
these are over-the-top action films
where one man can take on seemingly
hundreds of goons and only get slightly
winded by the end of it audiences are
always going to be expected to suspend
their disbelief to enjoy a film like
this one of the influences of John Wick
is the Spy play or suspension of
disbelief is Paramount
this is why we see John wear a cool suit
practice all manner of martial arts and
use specialized Tech
this case his Tech includes his
impenetrable black Kevlar suit jacket
what style I tell you how many buttons
two trousers tapered how about the
lining
tactical it's fun action movie logic
that a slick tailored suit can be made
of Kevlar and still be live and mobile
however why doesn't it cause recoil from
bullet hits it would on a stunt and
narrative level make the fights more
interesting if it didn't feel that Jon
had practically a force field protecting
him in every fight the shootout scenes
are still awesome and fun but the film
does lose a sense of danger in many of
the fights still for all our complaints
about the Kevlar suits Reeves makes it
look good
John Wick chapter 4 isn't a spiritual or
Supernatural film and neither were any
of the other films in the series in fact
at one point while Kane and Wick both
reminisce in a church before their duel
Kane asked John a pointed question you
think your wife can hear you
no
so it's surprising at the end that while
John slumps on the steps of the church
bleeding to death from his injuries in
Kane's bullet he sees visions of his
late wife Helen maybe I'm wrong and
given all the religious imagery
throughout the film such as The Final
Duel happening at a church and all the
religious terminology the Assassin
underworld speaks throughout the
franchise it seems like there could be a
religious connotation to Wick's death
after all by sacrificing his life to
save Kane's daughter he's absolved of
his past sins to live in eternity with
his beloved of course the most likely
answer for these intercut scenes of his
wife is that Jon's just remembering her
they're simply the last things he's
thinking about as he finally dies but
who can really say
[Music]
foreign